bah tu vois je voudrais plus de noël
dans l'année parce que parce qu'il ya
passe parce qu'il n'ya pas cette cadeau
vous devrez combien
rohff une dizaine je voudrais des patins
à roulettes pour quoi faire mais pour
quoi faire pour pouvoir patiner je pense
qu'il faudrait que leurs vertes soit
plus blanc rouge comme ça on pourrait
prendre nous les décisions ce serait
sympathique non moi je voudrais que qui
pleuvent la nuit puisque puis il faut et
le jour qui fasse beau temps quoi parce
que la nuit pour qu'il pleuve ce serait
bien pour les agriculteurs puis le jour
ce serait bien pour les vacanciers
comptes fasse beau toute l'année sur
tous les mois est beaucoup plus chaud
qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi et bien comme ça
on pourrait porter la mini jeux tout la
naissance au mouzon mourir de froid
ce serait beaucoup plus agréable pour
les commerçants du quartier
la mode revenir un peu sur les bas noirs
les petites coutures fou c'est sûr d
epuis jus peut raccourcir un petit peu
avec une petite fente sympathique
entrevoir les genoux